hi honey so let's say hypothetically
there's a young man here who is dating a
young woman who tends to lean very far
left so sorry before you go any further
is she is she present right now no she
isn't okay go check me out I said how
might do you have any advice for how
this young man might go about exposing
her to some new ideas without the
relationship crashing in for an optimist
so you my friend are making a very large
mistake
I'm sure she's wonderful I'm sure she's
supremely attractive I'm for all of
those things it depends what the
relationship is for are you in it for
marriage or like you actually have to
give me like what's the end goal here
yeah marriage okay so if you're in it
for marriage then the number one thing
you must have in common with your spouse
is values you don't have interests come
after values but most people are
interested in lots of things there are
lots of interesting things in the world
liking the same movies liking the same
art virtually worthless what is
important is that you have the same
value system so politics are reflection
of values now there are a lot of people
who never connect their politics with
their values so you have to determine
whether she's politically left because
this represents some core values or just
because she's been told a bunch of
slogans and now she repeats all these
slogans so when I first dated my wife
for example my wife thought of herself
as pro-choice and then the most and the
more that we discussed the issue became
very clear to her that she was actually
pro-life and hadn't really considered
the issue in a serious way it was just
she was told on college campus that was
a good thing to be pro-choice and so she
said she was pro-choice and the same
thing was true of gun rights for example
she didn't know anything about guns
she'd been told guns were bad and then
when I explained gun rights to her and
when it turned out that her father was a
member of the military then then she
then she shifted a little bit politics
is the tip of the iceberg the question
is whether you're your girlfriend's
politics or this unnamed persons
girlfriend's politics
are a floating bit of flotsam on the top
of the ocean or whether there's actually
a structural underpinning for what she's
thinking so you first have to determine
that if there is a structural
underpinning and if she really believes
this stuff on a strong level you're
really gonna have to think about whether
this is something you want to go through
for the next 80 years because it's
because when it comes time to raise your
kids I forget about you okay in my view
marriage is marriage not relationships
marriage is about bearing and rearing
children ideally I know my wife and I
have two children that is the end goal
of marriage that is the Telos of
marriage marriage was created so that we
could bear and raise our children and
that means that we have to have very
similar perspectives on how we want to
raise our kids now if you want to raise
your kid with traditional ideas of
virtue and decency and she wants to
raise your kids with traditional ideas
of multiculturalism for example then in
all cultures and all opinions being
equal all behavior being equal this is
gonna be a real conflict when it comes
time to parent your kids so you so you
have to ask yourself two questions one
is she movable and two if she's not
movable what is your end goal here
because you know there's lots of fun to
be had in life but when it comes time
for marriage marriage is as all the
married people in the room know marriage
is not the time for fun you know
marriage is is know when it comes when
it comes time for marriage you know I've
not totally Durai love my wife and we
have a great marriage but see I know
she's watching but it's it but but yeah
when it comes time for marriage it is
deeply important that you put values
before all of the other ancillary things
if you have values in common your
marriage can outlast anything if you
don't have values in common then the
first break and the thing is over